Tag 2 auf unserem neuen Bauernhof dieser
Rasenmäher wollte beim besten Willen
nicht anspringen aber es ist ja nicht so
als gäbchen nichts anderes zu tun also
haben wir verschiedene fußbodenöle
ausprobiert um uns für eine Farbe zu
entscheiden das ganze musste erstmal
trocknen also sind wir in die Scheune
gegangen da gibt es nämlich so unendlich
viel zu entdecken wie findet ihr z.B
diese Schuhe ziemlich schick oder ich
habe gehört dass der Bauer der hier
früher gewohnt hat auf dem ganzen
Grundstück Schätze versteckt haben soll
mal gucken ob wir irgendwann noch einen
von denen finden dann waren wir richtig
hungrig von der ganzen harten Arbeit und
deswegen habe ich hier diese ultra
leckeren gemüsetaschen gemacht und dann
ist das schlechte Gewissen immer größer
geworden dass wir immer noch nichts
geschafft haben deswegen habe ich mich
wieder zum Fußboden gegeben und gemerkt
dass ich absolut nicht das richtige
Equipment habe um den zu ölen aber wir
probieren das jetzt mal mit unserer Brot
Backform und dieser Farbrolle ich bin
echt der größte nubi was diese ganzen
renovierungsthemen angeht ich finde
morgen gehen wir mal raus und kümmern
uns um das Gartenhäuschen